bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france les plages sont donc rouverte
mais pour un usage dynamique qui peut
aujourd'hui profiter de la plage alors
tout le monde aujourd'hui peut profiter
de la plage à condition de ne pas rester
sur le sable donc les surfers bien sûr
qu'on était les premiers à appeler de
leurs voeux la réouverture des plages
les baigneurs le sauvetage côtier et
puis tous les marcheurs on est sur la
grande plage de biarritz on voit les
familles qui se promènent à condition de
ne pas planter le parasol de ne pas
planter la glacière et de marché mais
c'est déjà un premier pas vers le retour
à la plage pour tous le parasol et les
journées en famille comme on les aime
et alors quelles mesures ont été prises
à biarritz pour éviter les
rassemblements qui sont donc toujours
interdite pour faire respecter les
gestes barrière la distanciation sociale
les gens on était les citoyens biarrots
étaient relativement respectueux pendant
cette phase de confinement est donc le
déconfinement se passe plutôt bien la
difficulté à mon sens va être la
réouverture des bars et des restaurants
puisqu'on a une culture du rassemblement
dans le centre ville de biarritz et
autour des bars dans lequel on aime
voilà bien être les uns contre les
autres
pour l'instant les biarrots jouent le
jeu beaucoup de masques même si on nous
faisait remarquer il ya encore quelques
quelques minutes que le port du masque
n'est pas suffisamment respectés en tout
cas n'ya pas d'arrêté obligeant les
promeneurs à utiliser un masque
la rentrée des écoles s'est relativement
bien passé même si peu d'élèves sont
rentrés sont rentrés à l'école donc pour
nous la difficulté va être de réussir la
réouverture était surtout des bars et
des restaurants
on imagine aussi que ce premier week end
et confine est aussi un premier test à
la proche de deux week-ends prolongés
alors c'est un test c'est un test pour
les locaux puisque comme vous l'avez
rappelé il y à la distance des 100 km ce
qui fera que nous n'aurons pas
habituellement nos touristes en
provenance de toulouse de bordeaux ou
même de paris qui constitue quand même
le gros des troupes ans et un week-end
prolongé
donc ça sera ça sera les locaux qui
profite trop qui profiteront de biarritz
et bien évidemment dans la mesure aussi
où les hôtels ne sont pas ouverts ça
sera un manque à gagner et on ne sera
pas dans une période
à mon sens difficile justement est ce
que c'est une nécessité aussi la
réouverture de ces places ne serait ce
que pour les locaux quelles sont les
conséquences économiques du confinement
à biarritz que pèse le tourisme dans les
finances de la commune
c'est l'activité la plus importante que
ce soit la ville où que ce soit la
région le pays basque que nous dépendons
de l'activité touristique et de
l'aéronautique dont vous savez que c'est
également un secteur qui est touché de
plein fouet
pour nous la réouverture des plages
marqué en fait de façon symbolique le
retour à la vie normale
les plages sont également un élément
d'attractivité très forte pour inciter
les touristes à venir et à être bien sûr
hébergés dans nos hôtels donc il est
extrêmement important que la vie puisse
reprendre son cours le plus normale
possible très très rapidement puisque
pratiquement la totalité des emplois que
ce soit les commerces les hôtels la
restauration comme je voulais dit
dépendent de cette réouverture des
plages et de la réouverture taux courts
alors évidemment la question est dans
tous les esprits aujourd'hui
finalement comment en un mot relancer
l'activité touristique en évitant une
seconde vague de contamination
c'est bien là la question c est trouver
des solutions des solutions innovantes
qui consiste à faire de cette plage pour
tous une plage dans lequel on ne va pas
être trop les uns sur les autres
à l'heure actuelle il ya des groupes de
travail qui essaye de trouver des
solutions qui ressemble pas à ce qu'on a
vu sur les premières propositions
italiennes notamment de plexiglas mais
effectivement on est haute pour les
restaurants ça va être la même
la même équation difficile comment avoir
du monde sans être entassés les uns sur
les autres puisque en plus on a cette
culture à biarritz et dans le sud de la
proximité de la convivialité
et donc voilà l'équation elle reste à
trouver merci beaucoup maïder arostéguy
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes un
conseilleur municipal est candidate elle
est républicaine à la mairie à 2
biarritz